While you're recovering from your visit from Santa, the people in Slovenia are recovering from visits from three separate Santas in this all-time classic Christmas edition of 99PI. We're taking this holiday week off. I hope you have some time off too. Enjoy. Oh, and a quick note. The following story acknowledges the existence of Santa Claus and explores his origin
就在你还在从圣诞老人的造访中恢复元气时，斯洛文尼亚人正在从三个不同圣诞老人的造访中恢复过来。欢迎收听本期99PI的经典圣诞特辑。我们将在这个假期周休息。希望你也能抽空休息一下。祝你过得愉快。哦，顺便提一下。接下来的故事承认圣诞老人的存在，并探讨了他的起源
story. Wing Quake. If you or someone in the car seat next to you are not ready to hear that, well, you might want to save this episode for another time. This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Slovenia is a small country in central Europe, nestled between Italy, Austria, Croatia, and Hungary. It's a land of snowy white peaks, green valleys,
故事。风之地震。如果你或车里坐在你旁边的人还没准备好听这些，嗯，你可能想把这集留到以后再听。这里是《无形之物》（99% Invisible）。我是罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）。斯洛文尼亚是中欧的一个小国，坐落在意大利、奥地利、克罗地亚和匈牙利之间。这是一个白雪皑皑的山峰、绿色山谷的土地，
intercoise rivers, beautiful in all seasons, although especially at Christmas time. It snowed really early on during my first winter here, and it was just magical. It felt like I was walking through a Christmas card. That's reporter Will Aspenar. I moved here from the UK with my wife and young family back in 2018 because we were enchanted with Slovenia's landscape
交错的河流，四季皆美，尤其是圣诞节期间。我在这里度过的第一个冬天，雪下得很早，简直太神奇了。感觉就像走在一张圣诞卡片里。记者威尔·阿斯帕纳尔（Will Aspenar）如是说。2018年，我和妻子及年幼的家人从英国搬到了这里，因为我们被斯洛文尼亚的风景迷住了
and wanted a new life for the kids. And in that first year, we were really curious what Christmas was going to be like in this snow globe of a country. We love Christmas, and I thought we did it pretty well back in Britain. But let's just say what Slovenia gets up to every December kind of blew us away. Like children in the US or the UK, Slovenian kids are visited by Santa Claus every Christmas Eve. They call him Bozicek. These are the voices of kids that I recorded at my daughter Marnie's elementary school.
，并想为孩子们开启一种新的生活。在那第一年里，我们很好奇在这个像雪球一样的国家里，圣诞节会是什么样子。我们热爱圣诞节，我以为我们在英国时过得相当不错。但这么说吧，斯洛文尼亚每年12月所做的事情还是让我们大开眼界。就像美国或英国的孩子一样，斯洛文尼亚的孩子们每个平安夜都会迎来圣诞老人的造访。他们管他叫博日切克（Bozicek）。这些是我在女儿马妮（Marnie）的小学里录下的孩子们的录音。
I like Santa because he brings me sweeties and put us in. And that's Marnie translating. But kids in Slovenia don't have to settle for just one Santa. They also have a more traditional option available, a Catholic saint called Miklaus, who dishes out the gifts on the night of December the 5th. My name is Morsje,, we're in a little bit. We like to be in a clash because when you go to the show, he throws down sweeties and
我喜欢圣诞老人，因为他给我带糖果，还把我们放进去。这是马妮的翻译。但斯洛文尼亚的孩子们不必满足于只有一个圣诞老人。他们还有一个更传统的选择，一个叫做米克劳斯（Miklaus）的天主教圣徒，他在12月5日的晚上分发礼物。我叫莫尔斯耶（Morsje），我们这就进去一点。我们喜欢去上，因为当你去看演出时，他会扔下糖果，
also brings presents. And if you're a kid in Slovenia, I think a G's, too, San is just really doesn't feel like enough. Well, don't worry. There is yet another option. He's a festive figure who comes down from the country's highest mountain every New Year's Day to shower the children of Slovenia with good wishes and yet more presence. His name, if you didn't catch it, is Derek Marass, grandpa Frost.
还会带来礼物。如果你是斯洛文尼亚的孩子，我觉得，嗯，单单一个圣诞老人真的远远不够。不过别担心。还有另一个选择。他是一个节日人物，每年元旦从该国最高的山峰下来，为斯洛文尼亚的孩子们送上美好的祝愿和更多的礼物。他的名字，如果你没听清的话，叫德里克·马拉思（Derek Marass），也就是严寒爷爷。
It was good to see you, but it was a good thing. It was good because we took a picture with him and had a fun time. If you're doing your sums, that means that this nation of just over 2 million people is visited by not one, not two, but three different centers every festive season. As far as I know, they have the highest Santa to citizen ratio of any country in the world. When I found out about Slovenia's three centres, I had so many questions. Why was one centre not enough for these people? Where on earth did they all come from? And how did they manage to coexist?
很高兴见到你，但这很好。这很好，因为我们和他合了影，度过了一段欢乐的时光。如果你算一笔账，这意味着这个人口刚过200万的国家，在每个节日期间都会迎来不仅一个、两个，而是三个不同的圣诞老人的造访。据我所知，他们拥有世界上任何国家中最高的圣诞老人与公民比例。当我发现斯洛文尼亚有三个圣诞老人时，我有一连串的疑问。为什么对这些人来说一个圣诞老人还不够？他们到底是从哪里冒出来的？他们又是如何共存的呢？
It turns out that each centre has had his moment in the spotlight, each in a different period of Slovenia's complicated history. And today, if you want a Christmas season that reflects that history and speaks to all Slovenians, you need all three magical men. The people of Slovenia have long been protective of their customs and language, and you can understand why. For hundreds of years, they were ruled by the Habsburg Empire, one of the most powerful dynasties in Europe. Their language superficially was German because they were part of the empire. That's art historian and self-described anglophone cheerleader of Slovenia, no acharney.
事实证明，每个圣诞老人都在斯洛文尼亚复杂的历史的不同时期大放异彩。今天，如果你想要一个既反映这段历史又能与所有斯洛文尼亚人产生共鸣的圣诞季，你需要这三个神奇的男人。斯洛文尼亚人民长期以来一直在保护他们的风俗和语言，你可以理解这是为什么。几百年来，他们一直受哈布斯堡王朝的统治，这是欧洲最强大的王朝之一。他们的语言表面上是德语，因为他们是帝国的一部分。艺术史学家、自封的斯洛文尼亚英语拉拉队队长诺阿·查尼（Noa Charney）如是说。
But anyone living at home and going about their daily activities would have spoken Slovenian. And so that preservation of the language has helped keep them a relatively homogenous solid group despite all of the issues that plagued Europe over the past centuries. The Slovenes were a distinct group of people with their own language but they did share the same religion with almost all other subjects of the Habsburg Empire, Roman Catholicism. Roman Catholics loved their saints, and around Christmas time, there was only one saint that mattered. Inter-Slovenia's first magical Christmas man, St. Nicholas. St. Nicholas, or Sveti McLeodshin's Levine, was a bishop born in the third century's CE.
但在家里生活、进行日常活动的人都会说斯洛文尼亚语。因此，这种语言的保护有助于使他们保持一个相对同质、团结的群体，尽管过去几个世纪欧洲饱受各种问题困扰。斯洛文尼亚人是一个独特的群体，有自己的语言，但他们与哈布斯堡王朝几乎所有其他臣民一样，拥有相同的宗教信仰——罗马天主教。罗马天主教徒热爱他们的圣徒，在圣诞节前后，只有一个圣徒是重要的。斯洛文尼亚的第一位神奇圣诞老人登场了：圣尼古拉斯。圣尼古拉斯（St. Nicholas），或称斯韦蒂·麦克劳申·斯利维内（Sveti Maklaushinslivene），是一位生于公元三世纪的主教。
or Svetima Klauschenslivene was a bishop born in the third century's CE. There are a lot of stories that surround St. Nicholas. Some of them very gory and unchristmacy, but the one that matters for our purposes is about a poor old man who got so desperate he was about to sell his daughters into prostitution. St. Nicholas intervened by delivering bags of gold coins to the man's house in the middle of the night. St. Nick coming in with an extremely intense origin story. And his St. day on December 6 is when Slovenian children traditionally received presents while they were sleeping, just like those bags of gold one and a half
或称斯韦蒂·麦克劳申·斯利维内（Sveti Maklaushinslivene），是一位生于公元三世纪的主教。围绕圣尼古拉斯有很多故事。其中一些非常血腥，一点也不像圣诞节，但对我们而言重要的那个故事讲的是一个可怜的老人，他走投无路，甚至打算把女儿卖去卖淫。圣尼古拉斯在半夜往这个人的家里送去了几袋金币，从而进行了干涉。圣尼古拉斯带着一个极其强烈的起源故事登场了。在12月6日他的纪念日这天，斯洛文尼亚的孩子们传统上会在睡觉时收到礼物，就像一个半世纪前的那些金袋子一样
millennia ago. But the action really happened the night before during Miklausje Vagnje, St. Nicholas Eve. In the capital of L'Abyana, there was a church-sponsored parade with Mikhail Shavanyye at the center dressed like a Catholic bishop with that iconic pointed hat, golden slippers, and a curling bishop staff. St. Nicholas in the Slovenian tradition is kindly, but he's accompanied by a group of little demons called Parclinni. And their role is essentially as a tool to be used by parents to frighten children into being obedient. And these Parclinni
几千年前。但真正的重头戏发生在头天晚上的米克劳斯耶·瓦涅（Miklausje Vagnje），即圣尼古拉斯前夜。在首都卢布尔雅那，有一场教堂赞助的游行，米克劳斯耶·瓦涅是游行的核心，他打扮成天主教主教的模样，戴着标志性的尖顶帽、穿着金色拖鞋、拿着弯曲的主教手杖。斯洛文尼亚传统中的圣尼古拉斯是慈祥的，但陪伴他的是一群被称为帕尔克利尼（Parclinni）的小恶魔。他们的角色本质上是父母用来吓唬孩子以使其听话的工具。而这些帕尔克利尼
these demons are supposed to carry around clanking chains that they drag you off with. That is intensely spooky for our Christmas story. Yeah, Michelash Lavagne really knocks Halloween into a cocked hat. Some of the people I spoke to were genuinely traumatized by it because in rural areas, people would actually dress up as these demons and take the opportunity to torment local children. Mikhail Aashevaniy was Slovenia's only Santa for generations, until the 1940s when the country traded one empire for another and swapped Santa's in the process. When the Austro-Hungarian Empire crumbled after World War I, the Slevingh peoples decided
这些恶魔应该带着叮当作响的链子到处走，把人拖走。对于我们的圣诞故事来说，这真是极其诡异。没错，米克劳斯·瓦涅（Michelash Lavagne）真把万圣节比得黯然失色了。我交谈过的一些人对此真正受到了心理创伤，因为在农村地区，人们实际上会打扮成这些恶魔，并借此机会折磨当地的孩子。几代人以来，米克劳斯·瓦涅一直是斯洛文尼亚唯一的圣诞老人，直到20世纪40年代，该国经历了一个帝国换另一个帝国，并在过程中更换了圣诞老人。第一次世界大战后奥匈帝国崩溃时，斯洛文尼亚人民决定
to join a collection of six nations who identified themselves ethnically as southern or Yugo Slavs. Yugoslavia was born. At first Yugoslavia was a monarchy, but after World War II it became a communist country led by a charismatic strong man named Yosep Bras, better known as Tito. Under Tito, Catholicism was suppressed and St. Nicholas aka McClaush was banned. So after the World War II, the new Yugoslav communist authorities wanted to banish religious customs from public life and they wanted to replace them with the new, let's say, socialist holidays. That's Nina Gitto, a curator at the Sylvine Ethnographic Museum, who has researched this period. And I must say that I even met one man.
加入六个国家的集合，这些国家在族群上认定自己是南方人或南斯拉夫人。南斯拉夫诞生了。起初南斯拉夫是一个君主国，但第二次世界大战后，它变成了一个由一位名叫约瑟普·布罗斯（Yosep Bras）、更为人所知的名字是铁托（Tito）的富有个人魅力的强人领导的共产主义国家。在铁托统治下，天主教遭到压制，圣尼古拉斯也就是麦克劳什（McClash）被禁。因此，在第二次世界大战后，新的南斯拉夫共产主义当局希望将宗教习俗从公众生活中驱逐出去，并希望用新的，比方说，社会主义节日取代它们。斯洛文尼亚人种学博物馆（Sylvine Ethnographic Museum）研究过这一时期的馆长妮娜·吉托（Nina Gitto）如是说。我必须说，我甚至遇到过一个人。
He was playing the role on Sam Nikolas and then the police came. And he told to me that he was in the prison for two days because of playing the role of San Nicolas. Bannering dressing up as a Catholic saint was one thing, but taking away presents for children during the darkest month of the year would have been unforgivable. Tito knew that, and so he needed something or rather someone to take Maclauch's place.
他当时在扮演圣尼古拉斯的角色，然后警察就来了。他告诉我，他因为扮演圣尼古拉斯的角色而在监狱里呆了两天。禁止扮成天主教圣徒是一回事，但在一年中最黑暗的月份里剥夺孩子们的礼物是不可原谅的。铁托深知这一点，因此他需要某种东西，或者更确切地说某个人来取代麦克劳什。
Exit Maclauch, enter our next magical Christmas man. At this point Yugoslavia relied on the Soviet Union for economic assistance, and Tito decided to borrow from its culture too. Since the 1930s, the Soviet Union had deployed a communist center to hand out the gifts. And that figure is called in Russian dead mortals, or grandfather Frost, in Slovenia he's called Dedek Miraz. Dedek Miraz looked like an enormous bearded man from the Russian countryside. We would appear in factories, and if we're being pragmatic he was probably someone from the factory team dressed up.
麦克劳什退场，我们的下一个神奇圣诞老人登场。此时的南斯拉夫依靠苏联的经济援助，铁托决定也从苏联的文化中借鉴。自20世纪30年代以来，苏联就部署了一位共产主义圣诞老人来分发礼物。这个人物在俄语中被称为“严寒老人”（Ded Moroz），在斯洛文尼亚被称为德代克·米拉兹（Dedek Miraz）。德代克·米拉兹看起来像一个来自俄罗斯乡村的高大胡子老头。我们会出现在工厂里，如果我们务实一点的话，他很可能是工厂团队里某个人假扮的。
The children would come to the factory and then they would have this positive association with going to the factory. And the parents would feel that the factory was the one giving the gifts to their children. And if this is good communist alternative to Catholic St. Nicholas or capitalist Santa Claus. But a political crisis threatened to end, Dedicmarass before he had even had a chance to spread the holiday cheer. Joseph Stalin wanted Yugoslavia to become a puppet state for the Soviet Union, but Tito
孩子们会来到工厂，然后他们会对去工厂产生这种积极的联想。而父母们会觉得工厂才是给他们孩子送礼物的地方。如果说这是对天主教圣徒圣尼古拉斯或资本主义圣诞老人的一个很好的共产主义替代品。但是一场政治危机威胁要在德代克·马拉思（Dedic Marass）甚至还没有机会传播节日欢乐之前就终结他。约瑟夫·斯大林（Joseph Stalin）希望南斯拉夫成为苏联的傀儡国，但铁托
was having none of it. And Stalin didn't take kindly to Tito's independent streak. There is clear evidence that Stalin tried to have him assassinated on at least 20 different occasions, including with such James Bond-like gadgetry as a music box that released nerve gas. Tito eventually outlawed all Soviet influence in Yugoslavia, but he wanted to keep Detic Miras, just not dressed like a Russian. You wanted to, you know, you just love him up a bit. But Tito's initial attempts were a little haphazard.
根本不买账。斯大林对铁托的独立倾向并没有表现出好感。有明确的证据表明，斯大林曾试图在至少20个不同的场合暗杀他，包括使用诸如能释放神经毒气的八音盒这样具有詹姆斯·邦德风格的小玩意。铁托最终在南斯拉夫取缔了所有苏联的影响力，但他想保留德代克·米拉兹，只是不想让他打扮得像个俄罗斯人。你想要，你知道的，你只是稍微让他本土化一点。但铁托最初的尝试有点杂乱无章。
Over the next few Christmases, Grandpa Frost appeared dressed up as a soldier, a minor, a sailor, even a striking worker. Basically, socialist archetypes of Yugoslav proletarian heroes. Yeah, at the beginning, it was quite political. Like the Dekmeras was bringing the greetings Slav proletarian heroes. But neither the original recipe Russian-dedic morass, or the Yugoslavian cosplay version really caught on in Slovenia.
在接下来的几个圣诞节里，严寒老人打扮成士兵、矿工、水手，甚至罢工工人。基本上都是南斯拉夫无产阶级英雄的社会主义原型。是的，一开始，这相当具有政治色彩。就像德代克·马拉思（Dekmeras）带来的是无产阶级英雄的问候。但无论是原汁原味的俄式严寒老人，还是南斯拉夫的Cosplay版本，在斯洛文尼亚都没有真正流行起来。
The people just didn't buy it, it felt phony, and so Tito decided to allow each of the six Yugoslav nations, including Slovenia, to design their own bespoke version of Grandpa Frost. In Slovenia, this country that had long been a part of a bigger empire, took the opportunity to redesign Detic Moras and turn him into something distinctly Slovenian. A 69-year-old painter called Maxine Gaspari was brought in to handle the design. This was a genius decision because although Gaspari was a classically trained artist, he was first and foremost a commercial illustrator with a broad fan base, I think of him as a Slovenian Norman Rockwell.
人们根本不买账，感觉很虚假，于是铁托决定允许包括斯洛文尼亚在内的南斯拉夫六个国家各自设计他们专属版本的严寒老人。在斯洛文尼亚，这个长期处于更宏大帝国之中的国家，借此机会重新设计了德代克·莫拉斯（Detic Moras），将其变成了一个具有鲜明斯洛文尼亚特色的形象。一位名叫马克西姆·加斯帕里（Maxine Gaspari）的69岁画家被请来负责设计。这是一个绝妙的决定，因为尽管加斯帕里是一位受过古典训练的艺术家，但他首先是一位拥有广泛粉丝基础的商业插画家，我认为他就像是斯洛文尼亚的诺曼·洛克威尔（Norman Rockwell）。
And when it came to Christmas, Gaspari knew what would appeal to as many Slovenians as possible. He tends to be known to the general public because he did this series of paintings that were made into postcards and collectibles of folk scenes related to the Christmas holiday. They're very tweey now, but this was the Christmas aesthetic that people would be used to in Slovenia.
当谈到圣诞节时，加斯帕里知道什么最能吸引尽可能多的斯洛文尼亚人。他之所以广为人知，是因为他创作了一系列描绘圣诞节相关民间场景的画作，这些画被做成了明信片和收藏品。现在看来它们非常小家碧玉，但这正是斯洛文尼亚人习惯的圣诞审美。
In 1952, Kaspari created three postcards of his new updated Slovenian version of Dedek Maras. He's smoking an old-fashioned decorated pipe that is associated with this one small town in the mountains. He's got a long sheepskin coat with these ancient Slovenian flower motifs on the coat tails, and he's got a hat made out of doormice for her. Doormice was one of the few sources of protein available to the rural poor, and it takes a lot of doormice to make a hat. And Dedek Muras is like that. He is a trapper who hunts doormice. he is not wealthy, but what wealth he has, he shares by bringing gifts to children.
1952年，加斯帕里为他全新更新的斯洛文尼亚版德代克·莫拉斯创作了三张明信片。他抽着一根与山区某个小镇有关的老式装饰烟斗。他穿着一件长羊皮大衣，大衣尾部有古老的斯洛文尼亚花卉图案，还戴着一顶用睡鼠皮做成的帽子。睡鼠是农村穷人仅有的蛋白质来源之一，要做成一顶帽子需要消耗很多睡鼠。而德代克·穆拉斯（Dedek Muras）就是这样。他是一个捕猎睡鼠的捕猎者。他并不富有，但他所拥有的财富都会通过给孩子们带去礼物来与人分享。
Sovenian fairy tales are full of modest and humble heroes who rise to the challenge when needed. Mountain men ready to answer the call. So Gospari was making sure that his dead egg morais spoke directly to the character of the people. A voluntary organization called the Association of Friends of Youth was in charge of the Dead-Eck-Marras rollout. They made 10 identical costumes from Gaspar's designs,
斯洛文尼亚童话里充满了在需要时挺身而出的温和谦逊的英雄。随时准备响应召唤的山地汉子。因此，加斯帕里确保了他的德代克·莫拉斯直击人民的性格。一个名为“青年之友协会”（Association of Friends of Youth）的志愿组织负责德代克·莫拉斯的推广工作。他们根据加斯帕里的设计制作了10套一模一样的服装，
and in 1952, the new Dead-Eck-Marras made appearances in and around the capital. This was followed by a booklet called Dead-Eck-Marras Pre-Higher. Dead-Eck-Marras is coming in 1957. The booklet had one main instruction. Dedic Marass was a fairy tale figure designed only for kids. He wasn't a piece of state propaganda the way Stalin or Tito had treated him.
并在1952年，全新的德代克·莫拉斯在首都及周边地区公开亮相。随之而来的是一本名为《德代克·莫拉斯要来了》（Dead-Eck-Marras Pre-Higher）的小册子。《德代克·莫拉斯要来了》将于1957年出版。这本小册子有一个主要说明。德代克·莫拉斯是一个专门为儿童设计的童话人物。他不是斯大林或铁托对待他的那种国家宣传工具。
He was fun. Translators into English, the booklet said, Dedic Marass is not a didactic figure, but a lively, cheerful, witty, fairy tale figure that sinks into the child's world so that the child comes to life with it. And it seems to have worked. I believe that Eddickmas was real, but I was younger. This is my friend Yasna, she was a child of the Slovenian 70s and 80s and grew up with a distinctly Slovenian, Eddickaz. You know, because you really saw him, because he came to kindergarten. He was not a fictional character, you know, that you see it only in TV or just hear stories
他是充满趣味的。翻译成英文，小册子写道：德代克·莫拉斯不是一个具有说教意味的人物，而是一个生动、开朗、风趣的童话人物，他融入了孩子们的内心世界，让孩子们与之一起焕发生机。这似乎奏效了。我相信德代克·莫拉斯（Eddickmas）是真的，但那时我还小。这是我的朋友亚斯娜（Yasna），她是斯洛文尼亚70年代和80年代的孩子，伴随着具有鲜明斯洛文尼亚特色的德代克·莫拉斯长大。你知道，因为你真的见到了他，他来到了幼儿园。你知道，他不是那种你只能在电视上看到或只听过关于他的故事的虚构人物
about him or, you know, he will come during night and no, he came in during day, he came to you. He gave you his hand, he hugged you, so it was a real person. And it gets better because they also hired one of the greatest writers of children's songs in Slovenia, Janis Beatens, to give Dedek Maraz his own catchy theme song. I don't remember the words. Just a second. Here it is.
或者，你知道的，他会在夜里来，不，他是白天来的，他来到了你身边。他握着你的手，拥抱了你，所以他是一个真实的人。更棒的是，他们还聘请了斯洛文尼亚最伟大的儿童歌曲作家之一扬尼斯·贝滕斯（Janis Beatens），为德代克·莫拉斯创作了他专属的洗脑主题曲。我不记得歌词了。等一下。在这里。
Aha. The wind blows, the wind blows, the wind blows, the wind blows, the wind blows, the wind blows, the wind blows, the wind blows, the wind blows, the wind blows, the wind blows, the wind blows, the wind blows, the wind blows, the wind blows, the wind blows, the wind blows, the wind blows, the wind blows, the wind blows, the wind blows, the wind blows, the wind blows, the wind blows, the wind blows, the wind blows, the wind blows, the wind blows, the wind blows, the wind blows, the wind blows, the wind blows, the wind blows, the wind blows, the wind blows, the wind blows, the wind blows, the wind blows, the wind blows, the wind blows, the wind blows, the wind blows, the wind blows, the wind blows, the wind blows, the wind blows, the wind blows, the wind blows, the wind blows, the wind blows, the wind blows, the wind blows, the wind blows, the wind blows, the wind blows, the wind blows, the wind blows, the wind blows, the wind blows, the wind blows, the wind blows, the wind blows, the wind blows, the wind blows, the wind blows, the wind blows, the wind blows, the wind blows, the wind blows, the wind blows, the wind blows, the wind blows, the wind blows, the wind blows, the wind blows, the wind blows, the wind blows, the wind blows, the wind blows, the wind blows, the wind blows, the wind blows, the wind blows, the wind blows, the wind blows, the wind blows, the wind blows, the wind blows, the wind blows, the wind blows, the wind blows, the wind blows, the wind blows, the wind blows, the wind blows, the wind blows, the wind blows, the wind blows, the wind blows, the wind blows, the wind blows, the wind blows, wind blows, the wind blows, the wind blows, the wind blows, the wind blows, the wind blows, the wind blows, the wind blows, the wind blows, the Good old dead egg morass Red bulls books notebooks dolls sleds and more. Oh, he's already come among us. Good old dead egg morass Yeah, maybe say sort of hello to Listeners in America on I'm dead egg morass. In English or in Slovenia? Slovenian, why not? Hey, post-dravoljeni drubiš. Nisam več, prou urnih nok, to da kajko čakame celku potrok. Post-dravoljeni usimoi poslušaoci. This Jolly Fellow is Robert Valtel. He started playing dead at Marass at the main parade in L'Abiana in 1987.
啊哈。风在吹，风在吹……（注：此处为歌词/歌声片段）亲爱的老德代克·莫拉斯，红牛的书、笔记本、洋娃娃、雪橇等等。哦，他已经来到我们中间了。亲爱的老德代克·莫拉斯，是的，也许可以对美国的听众说声好。我是德代克·莫拉斯。用英语还是斯洛文尼亚语？斯洛文尼亚语，为什么不呢？（斯洛文尼亚语问候）这位快乐的家伙是罗伯特·瓦尔特尔（Robert Valtel）。他于1987年在卢布尔雅那的主要游行中开始扮演德代克·莫拉斯。
Robert is quite a character in his own right. We talked for hours in his apartment alongside the love of his life, his dog Umbra. Okay, Umbra, Mir de Prosim. Mir, what breed is Umbra? Lagoto Romaniolo. Italian water dog.
罗伯特本身就是一个很有个性的人。我们在他的公寓里聊了几个小时，陪伴他的还有他的挚爱——他的狗翁布拉（Umbra）。好吧，翁布拉，安静，求你了。安静，翁布拉是什么品种？拉戈托罗马尼奥洛犬（Lagoto Romaniolo）。意大利水犬。
Fancy. Yeah, fancy, fancy. When Robert started performing as Derek Morass, Tito had been dead for seven years. And Yugoslavia was on a downward spiral to complete disintegration. But Slovenia was actually doing well economically and felt that the other republics were dragging her down.
真别致。是的，别致，真别致。当罗伯特开始扮演德代克·莫拉斯时，铁托已经去世七年了。南斯拉夫正处于走向彻底解体的下行螺旋中。但斯洛文尼亚的经济实际上表现良好，并觉得其他共和国在拖她的后腿。
So in 1991 Slovenians took their chances and declared independence from Yugoslavia. And it was fantastic. It was really fantastic because it was like almost everyone for the independence. Yasmina remembers this period feeling almost too good to be true. Yeah, it was scary a little bit because we knew that they wouldn't let us go. That easy. So it was exciting. And also, you know, you didn't know what will happen. And then when it happened, it was like...
所以在1991年，斯洛文尼亚人抓住机遇，宣布脱离南斯拉夫独立。这太棒了。这真的是太棒了，因为就像几乎所有人都支持独立一样。亚斯娜回忆起这段时期，感觉好得简直不像是真的。是的，有点可怕，因为我们知道他们不会轻易让我们走。所以这令人兴奋。而且，你知道，你不知道会发生什么。然后当它发生时，就像是……
Everything at once. On June the 24th, Robert and a group of actor friends were performing all over the capital. He still vividly remembers how happy everyone was in the hours leading up to Slovenia's formal declaration of independence. It was beautiful in Dubljana, everywhere, you know, happy people. So, and then we went to sleep, I don't know, four or five morning, and then started the alarm for the bumps. So, that was really shock. The Yugoslav Air Force dropped by and got some cannon canon at Slovenian militia targets throughout the day. But the war only lasted 10 days. Slovenia escaped the horror that befell many of the other former
一切瞬间爆发。6月24日，罗伯特和一群演员朋友在首都各地表演。在斯洛文尼亚正式宣布独立的几个小时前，大家是多么高兴，他至今仍历历在目。卢布尔雅那非常美丽，到处都是，你知道，人们都很高兴。所以，然后我们去睡觉了，我不知道，早上四点或五点，接着防空警报就响了。所以，那真的是一个震撼。南斯拉夫空军飞过，并在一天中对斯洛文尼亚民兵目标进行了一些轰炸。但这场战争只持续了10天。斯洛文尼亚躲过了20世纪90年代降临在许多其他前
Yugoslav nations throughout the 1990s. What happened in Croatia first and Bosnia, it's horrible. It's really horrible. But for Slovenia we were lucky. After centuries of being part of monocles, empires and failed six-part nation-states, Slovenia had achieved independence in under two weeks. But this victory led to a battle over Slovenian culture, one that almost spelled the end for Detic Miras. We were afraid that Dedek Miras can disappear. Because some people, they want you to know to kill him.
南斯拉夫国家身上的恐怖。克罗地亚和波斯尼亚发生的事情，太可怕了。真的太可怕了。但对于斯洛文尼亚来说，我们很幸运。在经历了几个世纪的单一民族帝国和失败的六部分民族国家之后，斯洛文尼亚在不到两周的时间内实现了独立。但这场胜利引发了一场关于斯洛文尼亚文化的战斗，这场战斗差点给德代克·莫拉斯敲响了丧钟。我们曾担心德代克·莫拉斯会消失。因为有些人，他们想要你，你知道的，杀了他。
Many Slovenes saw this moment as an opportunity to move into the modern world and reject everything from the past. And despite his fun Slovenian rebrand, some people still associate with the Soviet Union. But what was really funny? They want to replace him with Santa Claus. Inter Slovenia's third magical Christmas man, Santa Claus. The red suit wearing reindeer having rosy, cheeked jolly fellow that you probably are picturing right now thanks in part to the Coca-Cola Company. Their Christmas character was designed to be used in coca-ads starting in 1931, and like
许多斯洛文尼亚人将这一时刻视为迈向现代世界并拒绝过去一切的机会。尽管他经过了有趣的斯洛文尼亚式重塑，但有些人仍然把他与苏联联系在一起。但真正搞笑的是什么？他们想用圣诞老人取代他。斯洛文尼亚的第三个神奇圣诞老人——圣诞老人（Santa Claus）登场了。穿着红衣服、带着驯鹿、有着红润面颊的快乐老头，你现在脑海中浮现的形象，部分要归功于可口可乐公司。他们的圣诞节形象是为了在1931年开始的可口可乐广告中使用而设计的，就像
the beverage itself, their Santa Amage went nearly everywhere in the capitalist world. And suddenly Slovenia was a democratic capitalist friendly country and looking to America and looking to Western Europe and hoping for a brighter, more independent economic future. Well, if you're interested in economic futures and capitalism, then you want your Santa wearing red pajamas and bringing as many gifts as possible. Many Slovenians embraced Santa Claus, but this time the new Santa didn't push the old one off the stage. In the end, Detic Morass survived the transition from socialist Yugoslavia to democratic Slovenia.
饮料本身一样，他们的圣诞老人形象几乎走遍了资本主义世界的每一个角落。突然之间，斯洛文尼亚成了一个民主、资本主义友好的国家，望向美国，望向西欧，期盼着一个更光明、更独立的经济未来。好吧，如果你对经济未来和资本主义感兴趣，那么你会希望你的圣诞老人穿着红色睡衣，尽可能多地带来礼物。许多斯洛文尼亚人接受了圣诞老人，但这一次，新来的圣诞老人并没有把旧的挤下舞台。最终，德代克·莫拉斯在从社会主义南斯拉夫向民主斯洛文尼亚的过渡中存活了下来。
It's hard to say exactly why, but I can't help wonder if it's because he was so well designed. Even though he was a relatively new creation, Dic Morass was crafted to feel like he'd always been there, like he was an ancient artifact of Slovenian culture, and people like Gazna weren't going to let him go without a fight. It's still a part of our history. Why kill it? I grew up with it. I didn't grow up with Santa Claus.
很难说具体原因是什么，但我禁不住想知道，是不是因为他设计得太好了。尽管他是一个相对较新的创造，但德代克·莫拉斯的打造让人觉得他一直都在那里，就像他是斯洛文尼亚文化的古老文物一样，而像亚斯娜这样的人是不会轻易让他被淘汰的。这仍然是我们历史的一部分。为什么要毁了它？我是伴随着他长大的。我不是伴随着圣诞老人长大的。
Dedic Morass is a part of us. So no way. Totally, no way. Dagmarass and Santa Claus were side-by-side, sharing the Christmas spotlight. And that would have been enough for most countries. But there was a sleeping giant in this story, our first magical Christmas man
德代克·莫拉斯是我们的一部分。所以绝无可能。完全绝无可能。德代克·莫拉斯和圣诞老人并肩而立，共享圣诞聚光灯。对大多数国家来说，这就足够了。但这其中沉睡着一个巨头，我们的第一位神奇圣诞老人
who had never really gone away. Sveti Miklausch, the original Catholic St. Nick. While the government had banned public religious celebrations in the Yugoslav era, Catholic families still held festivities in private. Yeah, so after the independence, all these customs connected with the religion, they were again introduced in the public life. So, Sannikolas came back. And Robert Valtel, L'Obiana's go-to Detic Marass, actually played a key role in the clashes return. He believed that if Slovenia was to move on, it had to reconcile its past as a faithful Catholic nation.
从未真正离去。圣韦蒂·米克劳什（Sveti Miklausch），最初的天主教圣尼古拉斯。虽然南斯拉夫时期政府禁止公开的宗教庆祝活动，但天主教家庭仍然在私下举行庆祝活动。是的，所以在独立之后，所有与宗教相关的习俗又被引入了公众生活。所以，圣尼古拉斯回来了。卢布尔雅那的御用德代克·莫拉斯扮演者罗伯特·瓦尔特尔，实际上在圣尼古拉斯的回归中发挥了关键作用。他认为，如果斯洛文尼亚要继续前进，它就必须与作为一个虔诚天主教国家的过去达成和解。
When you show that they can be together, suny collos and grandpa Fros de de Kmiras, and that they can both say something nice and do something nice, it's a beautiful. And so in 1991, Robert, already the capitals go to De deick-Marass, decided to organize a parade from Miklouche. It was the first one since the Second World War, the saint's grand return to public life. Never shying away from a challenge, Robert decided to play the central role of Miklouche himself. You know, for me this is theatre. And when I work theatre, I want to do perfection. To get into character, only the most authentic costume for Sveti McClash would do. I ask the bishop of Rybljana to rent me, original, old, you know, Catholic bishop stuff,
当你展示他们可以并存时，圣尼古拉斯和严寒老人德代克·莫拉斯，他们都可以说些美好的话并做些美好的事，这太美妙了。因此，在1991年，已经是首都御用德代克·莫拉斯的罗伯特决定为米克劳斯组织一场游行。这是自二战以来的第一次，这位圣徒盛大回归公众生活。从不畏惧挑战的罗伯特决定亲自扮演米克劳斯的核心角色。你知道，对我说来这就是戏剧。当我在做戏剧时，我要做到完美。为了进入角色，只有最正宗的圣韦蒂·米克劳什服装才行。我请卢布尔雅那的主教租给我正宗的、古老的天主教主教法衣，
and I was really beautiful, even with the golden shoes. And ever since that moment, when Maclaus returned to the streets of the capital, Slovenia has had all three centers at Christmas time. And Slovenes have not only completely accepted all the three good men, Trey Dobri Moseye, they've been packaged together in a month of non-stop festivities called Mary of Vaselli December. Vaselli December, it's the whole month, you know, it's like the month of the parties and the happy stuff and that's why we have all three men because it's the whole month of
而且即使戴着金鞋，我也真的非常漂亮。从那时起，当马库拉斯重返首都街头时，斯洛文尼亚在圣诞节期间就拥有了全部三个中心。斯洛文尼亚人不仅完全接受了所有三个善良的人，特雷·多布里·莫谢耶，他们还在一个名为“快乐瓦塞利十二月”的整月不间断庆祝活动中被打包在一起。瓦塞利十二月，这是一个整月，你知道的，这就像是派对和快乐事物的月份，这就是为什么我们拥有所有三个男人，因为这是一个整月的
good and merry stuff. Each Santa gets its own specific time slot to perform their own brand of Christmas magic. First on the calendar is Maclaus. He appears at churches across the country and herades in the big cities on the evening of December 5th. I took my family to this parade in 2018. My daughter loved Maclaus, but she didn't react too well when his demon helpers first appeared. Oh my God! Oh my God!
美好而快乐的事物。每个圣诞老人都有自己特定的时间段来表演他们自己品牌的圣诞魔法。日历上的第一个是马库拉斯。他出现在全国各地的教堂里，并于12月5日晚上在大城市游行。我在2018年带我的家人去看了这场游行。我女儿很喜欢马库拉斯，但当他的恶魔助手第一次出现时，她的反应不太好。我的天哪！我的天哪！
Oh my God! Oh my God! Oh my God! Oh my God! My baby is so cute! Oh my God! Oh my God! They're a crying children including my own.
我的天哪！我的天哪！我的天哪！我的天哪！我的宝贝太可爱了！我的天哪！我的天哪！有许多哭泣的孩子，包括我自己的孩子。
That's a lot of screaming inter, for a Santa parade. Then comes Santa Claus or Bozy Check. Christmas Eve is obviously his allotted night, but he tends to hang around the shops and malls. And finally, there's Dedek Moras. He actually makes appearances in kindergarten and schools throughout December, but post Christmas time, he's the only Santa left on the scene. His parade happens around New Year's. My de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de de Over the course of reporting this story, I met performers of all three centers, including
对于一场圣诞老人游行来说，这真是一阵尖叫。接着是圣诞老人或博齐·切克。平安夜显然是他分配到的夜晚，但他往往会在商店和购物中心附近闲逛。最后，还有德代克·莫拉斯。他实际上在整個12月都会出现在幼儿园和学校里，但在圣诞节过后，他是现场仅存的圣诞老人。他的游行大约在新的一年举行。我的……在报道这个故事的过程中，我遇到了所有三个中心的表演者，包括
Robert, and they take their jobs extremely seriously. This is not carneval. This is something very important for children. Helping children is fundamental to Robert's role in the Slovenian Christmas, but it's not always easy. So the children, they're not all happy. They're not living all in happy families. And when they see, they have opportunity to speak
罗伯特，他们非常认真地对待自己的工作。这可不是狂欢节。这对孩子们来说是一件非常重要的事情。帮助儿童是罗伯特在斯洛文尼亚圣诞节中角色的核心，但这并不总是容易的。所以孩子们，他们并不都是快乐的。他们并非都生活在幸福的家庭中。当他们看到时，他们有机会说话
with the dekmeras. They can say a lot of sad things from their lives. He's asked you for help, like my father, beat my mother, he's an alcoholic. Please, did I ask, can I stay with you? I don't want to go home. That's really difficult. That's really difficult.
带着德克莫拉斯。他们可以从他们的生活中说出很多悲伤的事情。他向你寻求帮助，比如我父亲打我母亲，他是个酒鬼。求求你，我能问问，我能跟你待在一起吗？我不想回家。这真的很困难。这真的很困难。
I normally, I'm not social worker. I cannot really help to them. Yeah, it's a lot of frustrations also behind this, because how to really help? Robert's response really moved me. I always thought dressing up as a Santa would be an almost entirely wonderful experience, but it's clear that there's also this feeling of a real responsibility. All of the Santas are supposed to provide comfort to the kids of Slovenia,
通常情况下，我不是社会工作者。我真的帮不了他们。是的，这背后也有很多沮丧，因为究竟该如何真正提供帮助？罗伯特的回应深深地打动了我。我一直以为打扮成圣诞老人会是一次几乎完全美妙的经历，但很显然，这也有一种真正责任感的感觉。所有的圣诞老人都应该为斯洛文尼亚的孩子们带来安慰，
but according to Robert, it's dead at Maras they tend to most. The Santa designed for the Slovenian people by the Slovenian people. of Slovenia, but according to Robert, its deadic morass they turn to most, the Santa designed for the Slovenian people by the Slovenian people. Today almost no one thinks the deadic morass came from Soviet Union because we make completely new story. Slovenia has survived empires and a socialist autocracy to emerge as a proud independent state. Instead of repressing the past, it has embraced the centers that once defined it, coordinating a festive season that has a time and a place for all of them.
但据罗伯特所说，他们往往最倾向于找德代克·莫拉斯。这个由斯洛文尼亚人民为斯洛文尼亚人民设计的圣诞老人。斯洛文尼亚的……但根据罗伯特的说法，他们最青睐的是死去的莫拉斯，这个圣诞老人是由斯洛文尼亚人为斯洛文尼亚人民设计的。如今，几乎没有人认为死去的莫拉斯来自苏联，因为我们创造了一个全新故事。斯洛文尼亚历经帝国和社会主义独裁统治，最终成为一个自豪的独立国家。它没有压抑过去，而是拥抱了曾经定义它的各个中心，协调出一个拥有各自时间和地点的节日季。
How long have you got to be dead at Maraz? And who will you hand it on to? How long I will be Deleg Maraz? Who knows? I will try my best, but it's the paint of my health. So I already have some of my colleagues. They can replace me. And this will continue, for sure. Deleg Maraz will live forever.
你当德代克·莫拉斯多久了？你准备把这个职位传给谁？我会当多久的杰莱格·莫拉斯？谁知道呢。我会尽力而红，但这取决于我的健康状况。所以我已经有一些同事了。他们可以取代我。这肯定会继续下去。杰莱格·莫拉斯将永远活着。
for sure. Yeah, then we'll leave forever. Coming up after the break, we find out which of Slovenia's three sandals is the most popular of all. So I'm back with Porter, Will Aspinal. And, well, I just want to ask you a little bit more about how the Sanchez operate in Slovenia and society. When we talk about how they divide up the month of December, but does everyone, you know, celebrate each of them equally or did some of these political and religious factions that's recreated them sort of extended into today? Like, how does it really work with your average family?
一定的。是的，那将永远存在。中场休息后，我们将揭晓斯洛文尼亚三个凉鞋中哪一个最受欢迎。所以我和波特、威尔·阿斯帕纳尔一起回来了。而且，嗯，我只是想更多地了解这些桑切斯如何在斯洛文尼亚及其社会中运作。当我们谈论他们如何划分12月时，每个人，你知道的，都同等地庆祝他们所有人吗？还是说创造他们的这些政治和宗教派系中的一些已经延伸到了今天？比如，对普通家庭来说，这到底是怎么运作的？
Yeah, you can see that these three scientists do represent three tribes. If you like, MacLeodge goes with the Catholic faithful, dead in Marass with old school socialists and Santa Claus with, you know, the new coming aspirational consumers. But it's not quite as simple as that. You know, many parents with young children
是的，你可以看到这三个科学家确实代表了三个部落。如果你愿意的话，麦克莱奇与天主教信徒同行，死在马拉斯与老派社会主义者同行，而圣诞老人则与新来有抱负的消费者同行。但事情并没有那么简单。你知道，许多有幼儿的父母
will opt for all three, some will opt for one or two. I mean, my friend Yasner, when I asked her this question, she explained to me how each of the three scientists functioned in her life. Now, she comes from a coastal town called Copa, near Italy. The coast was more communist, red area, let's say, and we have only dead-eknests, though we knew Santa Claus because of Italy, because of the border, because they had Santa Claus. So after independence in 1991,
会选择全部三个，有些人会选择一个或两个。我的朋友亚斯娜，当我问她这个问题时，她向我解释了这三个科学家在她生活中的作用。现在，她来自一个靠近意大利的名为科帕的海滨小镇。海岸比较共产主义，可以说是红色地区，我们只有死去的eknests，虽然我们因为意大利、因为边界、因为他们有圣诞老人而认识圣诞老人。所以在1991年独立之后，
she moved north to the mountains close to the border with Austria, and then she married and had two kids. And as a parent, she welcomes all three sanders as a way of celebrating Mary December with both sides of the family. And usually we went for Christmas in copper. And from, for the new year, we were here. So in copper came Santa Claus.
她向北搬到了靠近奥地利边境的山区，然后她结婚并生了两个孩子。作为一名父母，她欢迎所有三个圣诞老人，以此作为与双方家庭共同庆祝快乐十二月的方式。通常我们在科帕过圣诞节。从新年开始，我们就待在这里。所以科帕来了圣诞老人。
And here came the decranas. And, okay, meclose,it was only for fruit and sweets, no toys. So we had also this. We have all three. So Mikhail Zhit is stuck with fruits and sweets, no toys. So how are you raising your kids, like all three sannas in their lives? I'm afraid it's totally unavoidable. It was Mickal Giovanni last night, so this morning, they received their stockings from
德克拉纳斯来了。好吧，米克洛斯，这只适合水果和糖果，没有玩具。所以我们也有这个。我们拥有全部三个。所以米哈伊尔·日特只吃水果和糖果，没有玩具？那你怎么抚养你的孩子，比如他们生活中的所有三个圣诞老人？恐怕这是完全不可避免的。昨晚是米克尔·乔瓦尼，所以今天早上他们收到了来自
Miklausch, and that's a new thing for them, which they have totally, they're very happy with, indeed, when they got a stuffed toy, they got a tangerine chocolate shaped like the devils and mclaus and a new book. But we also have obviously, we have Father Christmas as we call him in the UK Santa Claus Christmas Eve that he's coming up. Denik Morass, actually, we haven't been in the country for New Year's Eve, so we need to give that a go this year. Oh, so is Denik Morass coming to your house or to the kindergarten? It's still a bit of white and sea with the pandemic this year, but actually I track down the guy who is the Derek Maraz in our area. He's a wonderful man called Grega Antolin.
米克劳斯，对他们来说这是一件新鲜事，他们对此非常高兴，实际上，当他们得到一个毛绒玩具时，他们得到了一个形状像恶魔和米克劳斯的橘子巧克力和一本新书。但显然我们也有，就像我们在英国所说的那样，圣诞老人平安夜就要来了。德尼克·莫拉斯，事实上，我们在新年前夕不在国内，所以我们今年需要尝试一下。哦，那么德尼克·莫拉斯是来你家还是去幼儿园？今年由于疫情，事情仍然有些扑朔迷离，但实际上我找到了在我们地区扮演德里克·莫拉斯的那个人。他是一个了不起的人，名叫格雷加·安托林。
All three centers will survive because they are superheroes and we need superheroes. Before the pandemic, he would make his living doing live performances in Ken Gardens all over December. He had other jobs during the rest of the year. But obviously, with the pandemic in 2020, with the lockdown that we had, he had to think fast. Before Corona, we make in December life performances and now we must do something new because we were at home. His genius plan was that he would do an online videogram service for Slovenian kids. It was inspired by a US Santa graham video messaging service that he saw. And yeah, he decided to bring it to Slovenia. So, so, so, Sina Graham is like a video message from Santa, two kids,
所有的中心都会生存下来，因为他们是超级英雄，我们需要超级英雄。在疫情爆发之前，他整个12月都在各地的肯花园进行现场表演谋生。一年中的其余时间他还有其他工作。但显然，随着2020年疫情的爆发以及我们经历的封锁，他必须快速思考。在新冠病毒爆发之前，我们在12月进行现场表演，现在我们必须做一些新的事情，因为我们都在家。他的天才计划是为斯洛文尼亚儿童提供在线视频服务。这灵感来自于他看到的美国圣诞老人视频消息服务。是的，他决定把它带到斯洛文尼亚。所以，所以，所以，希纳·格雷姆就像是圣诞老人给两个孩子的视频信息，
and you said he plays Detic Marass in these. Not just Detic Marass. This is Slovenia, so he has to do all three. And that requires quite a little bit of financial outplay and planning because he needs not just three costumes which are pretty expensive because I've seen them and they are the real deal. I mean, this denim or ass one was almost $2,000. Wow, custom made. He then has to do three different sets and then he records a different video with each of the most common children's names in Slovenia. To be recorded, 150 names of boys and 150 names from girls, this was the most common names in past two years. Okay, so 150 girls names, 150 boys names,
你说他在这里面扮演了“Dedek Mraz”。不仅仅是“Dedek Mraz”，这里是斯洛文尼亚，所以他三个都要扮演。这需要相当一笔资金投入和规划，因为他不仅需要三套服装，而且非常昂贵，因为我亲眼见过，它们都是真材实料。我是说，这套“Dedek Mraz”的服装就要将近2000美元。哇，定制的。然后他必须准备三套不同的布景，接着用斯洛文尼亚最常见的儿童名字录制不同的视频。要录制150个男孩的名字和150个女孩的名字，这是过去两年中最常见的名字。好吧，也就是150个女孩的名字，150个男孩的名字，
that's 300 names for each Santa. So 300 times 3 is 900 names that he has to record and it has to work first time. So imagine retakes. Wow. That's really a lot of work. And then I should say that the parents can choose their Santa and they can choose the name and then they can choose the message. And cleaning teeth is a very high priority for Slovenian parents. So this is the message that's Santo or Maclouish or Dajmaras has to say, is to like be a good child this year and clean your teeth and then I'll bring your presents. Yeah, exactly. Classic. I really wish I really wish I could have seen it in person. I did
每个圣诞老人要录300个名字。所以300乘以3就是900个他必须录制的名字，而且必须一次成功。想象一下重新拍摄。哇。这真的是大量的工作。然后我得说，父母可以选择他们的圣诞老人，可以选择名字，还可以选择祝福语。而“刷牙”对斯洛文尼亚父母来说是极高的优先级。所以圣诞老人、Miklavž或Dedek Mraz要说的话就是：今年要做个好孩子，好好刷牙，然后我就会给你带礼物。对，没错。经典。我真的很希望、真的很希望我能亲眼见到。我
pass to him, but it was a close set. You got to keep these things secret. I mean, this is magical stuff we're talking about here. He did very kindly send me some sneak peeks of his performance. So would you like to hear some? Oh, absolutely. Let's hear them. Okay, first up, Santa Claus. Zabijem, da je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je je Oh yeah, and then okay, so next up we'll have McClash He's kind of like the previous one but but a little bit more adjunous voice. Exactly, and I'm afraid I've been here three years and I can pick out one or two words. I had Palkalny, I had the demons mentioned, but yeah, a little bit more serious maybe. So let's hear that again, Maraz. I really like this guy. He's dedicated to his craft. That's fantastic. Did he mention that he had a preference of which one he'd like to perform the most? He is a big fan of Death of Miras. Yeah. Yeah. I mean, they're all excellent. But like, there's like, you can,
去找过他，但那是封闭拍摄。你得把这些事情保密。我是说，我们谈论的是神奇的东西。他非常友好地给我发了一些他表演的抢先看片段。你想听听吗？哦，当然。让我们听听。好的，首先是圣诞老人。哦，太棒了。噢，耶，接下来我们要听的是Miklavž。他有点像前一个，但声音稍微中性一点。没错，恐怕我在这里待了三年，我能听出一两个词。我有Palkalny，我听到提到了恶魔，但是的，可能更严肃一点。所以让我们再听听那个，Mraz。我真的很喜欢这家伙。他致力于自己的手艺。这太棒了。他有没有提到他更喜欢表演哪一个？他是“Dedek Mraz”的超级粉丝。对。我是说，它们都很棒。但就像，你可以，
I mean, you mentioned that he spent $2,000 on the costume alone, that Death of Miras is really like, that's a great one. It's a great one and it's the Slovenian icon, isn't it? I think he really embodies it. But after the first year of data gathering from the Christmas 2020, he actually has this very unique data set of who is Slovenia's favorite digital center? Oh, because people order these custom videos, and so therefore he knows how many people want Santa versus Maclaus versus Dedek Maraz.
我是说，你提到他光是服装就花了2000美元，“Dedek Mraz”真的很棒，那是个了不起的角色。这是一个绝佳的角色，而且它是斯洛文尼亚的标志，不是吗？我觉得他真的将其体现得淋漓尽致。但在收集了2020年圣诞节第一年的数据后，他实际上得到了一个非常独特的数据集：谁是斯洛文尼亚人最喜欢的数字圣诞老人？哦，因为人们订购这些定制视频，所以他知道有多少人想要圣诞老人、Miklavž还是Dedek Mraz。
Oh, this is fascinating. Okay, so what was the result? The 80% ordered Santa Claus video. 15% was Dedek Maraz, and only 5% was mecklaus. Well, I mean, like, Santa Claus is great. You'll never get me disincenti-class. But I have to admit, I'm a little disappointed that that cameras isn't like really the most favorite in Slovenia, just because, you know, it's unique to Slovenia.
哦，这太迷人了。好吧，结果是什么？80%的人订购了圣诞老人的视频。15%是“Dedek Mraz”，只有5%是Miklavž。好吧，我的意思是，圣诞老人很棒。你永远无法让我放弃圣诞老人。但我必须承认，我有点失望的是，“Dedek Mraz”在斯洛文尼亚竟然不是最受欢迎的，只因为，你知道，它是斯洛文尼亚独有的。
That's what makes it so special. Yeah, you kind of want that cameras to be number one, don't you? But you do. You do. But the way I see it is that Santa Claus has got everything. As Greka says, he's got the TV, he's got the songs, most of the songs. He's got the merch, he's got the advertising. He's the king of the screen.
这就是它如此特别的原因。是的，你多少会希望“Dedek Mraz”排在第一位，对吧？但你的确会这么想。不过在我看来，圣诞老人拥有一切。正如Greka所说，他有电视，他有歌曲，绝大多数歌曲。他有周边商品，他有广告。他是屏幕之王。
And Slovenia, like any country, is as outward facing as it is inward. So I think to have 20% of Slovenian parents choosing on turns, it was actually pretty incredible. Yeah, yeah, that's a good point. That's a good point. Well, I'm totally fascinated by these three centers and how much they mean to the country and how much they sort of map onto the history of Slovenia. I just can't thank you enough for bringing the story to us. I just had a joy of, you know joy watching you make it and bring it to us. It's been fascinating. Thank you Roman, it's been a pleasure. 99% of visible was produced this week by Will Aspenal, edited by Emmett Fitzgerald and Joe Rosenberg. Sound mixed by Jim Briggs, music by Swan Rial,
而斯洛文尼亚，和任何国家一样，既面向外部也面向内部。所以我认为有20%的斯洛文尼亚父母选择传统形象，实际上已经相当不可思议了。对，对，这很有道理。这确实很有道理。好吧，我对这三个圣诞老人以及它们对这个国家的意义、它们如何对应斯洛文尼亚的历史深深着迷。我太感谢你把这个故事带给我们了。看着你制作并把它带给我们真是一种纯粹的快乐。这太迷人了。谢谢你，罗曼，这是我的荣幸。本周99% Invisible由Will Aspinall制作，Emmett Fitzgerald和Joe Rosenberg编辑。混音由Jim Briggs完成，音乐由Swan Rial提供，
Jenny Conley, Nate Query, and John Newfeld. Fact checking by Graham Haysha. Special thanks this week to Robert Kuznick. Kathy T. Wizzars, a kid of producer Delaney Hall as our senior editor, Colstedt, is our digital director. The rest of the team includes Sarah Baker, Chris Baroubaig, Christopher Johnson,
Jenny Conley、Nate Query和John Newfeld。事实核查由Graham Haysha完成。本周特别感谢Robert Kuznick。Kathy T. Wizzars，资深制片人Delaney Hall是我们的高级编辑，Colstedt是我们的数字总监。团队的其他成员包括Sarah Baker、Chris Baroubaig、Christopher Johnson、
Martin Gonzales, Vivian Le, Jason Delion, Lashmadan, Jacob Moltenano Medina, Kelly Prime, Gabriella Gladney, and me Roman Mars. The 99% of his below goat was created by Stefan Lawrence. We are part of the Stitcher & Serious XM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building. In beautiful. Uptown, Oakland, California. You know it's really beautiful about Oakland right now?
Martin Gonzales、Vivian Le、Jason Delion、Lashmadan、Jacob Moltenano Medina、Kelly Prime、Gabriella Gladney，以及我罗曼·马尔斯。99% Invisible的Logo由Stefan Lawrence设计。我们是Stitcher & Sirius XM播客家族的一部分，现在总部设在北边六个街区外的潘多拉大楼，位于美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心。你知道奥克兰现在真正美妙的地方是什么吗？
The Oakland Roots Soccer Club. As other teams come and go, the Roots are Oakland first. Always. You can find us on all the usual places on the internet, but if you want to see photos from Slovenia of Dedek Miras in action, open up a new browser tab and type in 99pi.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
奥克兰根基足球俱乐部（Oakland Roots Soccer Club）。当其他球队来来去去时，“根基队”永远属于奥克兰。你可以在互联网上所有常见的地方找到我们，但如果你想看到来自斯洛文尼亚的“Dedek Mraz”行动中的照片，请打开一个新的浏览器标签页并输入99pi.org。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。